[Music]
every year more than a million people in
the world die in road traffic accidents
and many of those fatalities are caused
by us by the mistakes we make as drivers
but there's a solution and it's a
relinquished control of the wheel to a
computer
we've dreamed about it for decades and
now we finally have the technology to
get us very close the rest is up to
these two they're teaching autonomous
cars how to drive my name is Samuel Andy
my name is Steven Lin and we're
autonomous vehicle operators
[Music]
daniela and stephen worked for start-up
called aurora and they're part of a team
of about two dozen specialists who drive
the company's fleet of self-driving cars
on the roads of pittsburgh palo alto and
here in san francisco
Aurora's software learns from their
expert example so to get this job they
had to be excellent drivers to start
with and to become even better they then
went through six weeks of training
[Music]
today I'm here at the Sonoma Raceway to
experience just a small part of that
training and to see if I have what it
takes to do this job before I hop in the
back of a self-driving vehicle myself
nobody actually I in my opinion knows
how to drive a car you all drove here
today so I'm not don't I'm not bashing
you right but do you know how to handle
a car when a car does something out of
the ordinary that's what today is all
about all right let's go have fun among
the first drills was emergency braking
[Music]
since Stephan and Daniela have already
completed this kind of training they're
here today to brush up on what they
already know and to show me how it's
done
good job
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then it was time for a series of
high-speed lane changes God's meshing
you're forced to suddenly swerve on the
highway to avoid an obstacle and for an
especially tricky challenge instructors
had us recover from a skid
let's just say it's a good thing no
self-driving car will be learning for me
anytime soon
the next week I went to go see Daniella
and Stephen at their office in San
Francisco
founded in 2017 by engineers from the
early autonomous vehicle projects at
Google Tesla and uber Aurora is
developing technology to power
self-driving cars and so far it's signed
deals with automakers including
Volkswagen and Hyundai Daniela and
Steven have invited me here to be the
very first reporter to sit in the back
of one of their self-driving cars is
ready up here we are ready okay we're
engaging now we're in Auto
backing the car ahead stopping so the
car right now is stopping on its own its
stopping on its own east banking is
making this issue's this is really cool
getting to see what the car sees yeah
what are these yellow boxes the yellow
boxes right there is that is a bicyclist
so it's so the car recognizes that this
is a bicyclist and if you see these kind
of blue boxes that means the vehicle
recognizes it as a vehicle and the red
boxes are pedestrians exactly
you're hired aura does a lot of its
testing virtually within the safety of a
simulation but to teach the system how
to react to all the crazy things that
happen in a city as nuts as San
Francisco you need to take it out in
real life what's the biggest
misconception your friends have about
your job that we just sit behind a wheel
and do nothing
Aurora's operators take turns as pilots
and co-pilots of the cars today Daniela
is a pilot I'm looking at everything I'm
thinking about everything planning for
everything if the car decides to bail
out in the middle of the intersection
what am I gonna do see how her hands are
ever so slightly touching the wheel her
foot hovering just above the brake she's
ready to take over in a fraction of a
second whenever she or the car senses
she needs to
and that's a bailout oh and I took over
the car saw something that was not
accurate and it gives me control as
Daniela's copilot today Stephens job is
to keep an eye on his laptop that shows
what the car sees getting a false
positive on the left
flickering he alerts Daniella to the
things she might not see with the naked
eye and prepares her for what the
self-driving system is about to do next
it's gonna want a left lane change as
the copilot Stephen is also taking notes
on when Daniela needs to intervene later
on the engineers will pour over this
data so they can figure out what went
wrong this is all part of the
painstaking process of teaching a
computer how to drive is a brain it's a
little baby brain that learns that your
heart ring yeah I call them my baby
robots because we're teaching them
[Music]
each operator at Aurora has
responsibilities outside the car -
Stephen assigns operators to drive the
routes the engineers need them to drive
and Daniela liaises with the team that
builds the maps that vehicles rely on
because driverless technology is so new
operators come from all kinds of
backgrounds and the job doesn't require
a special degree or prior industry
experience Daniela was a surgeon in
Mexico and worked for the fire service
after she moved to the States and
Stephen was a military police sergeant
in the army operators at aurora earned
about thirty to forty dollars an hour
and is full-time employees their
benefits include healthcare equity and
fitting of the tech company stereotype
free lunch you guys are teaching cars
how to drive and if you're successful
that is going to replace a lot of jobs
out there
uber drivers for example that's millions
of jobs think about that we've had
interactions where people tell us you
taking jobs away from people but I like
to say is imagine you're living in a
world where you don't have to worry
about drunk drivers you don't have to
worry about people who are texting out
their phones and you know just being
reckless you know we might lose some cab
driver jobs but we'll save millions of
lives in the long
in the future our cars aren't gonna need
the kind of intensive teaching that
Stephen and Daniella are doing now but
when it comes to the most high-stakes
life-or-death responsibilities that will
soon and trust the computers we're gonna
want human experts to be vetting those
capabilities for a very long time we're
still gonna be testing for perhaps new
features new avenues new ways to use
self-driving technology and other types
of vehicles so I don't believe this job
will disappear anytime soon
[Music]
you